hallo cmor hallo klickom ich habe ein
paar Fragen an Colm und zwar erstens von
was wirst du für deine wunderbaren
Videos inspiriert und die zweite Frage
ist du hast selbst mal Gentleman gefragt
wegen seiner Religiosität und ich möchte
wissen bist du religiös glaubst du an
die Bibel glaubst du an Gott oder nicht
danke für deine Antwort und ich freue
mich ja ich kann leider gar nicht so
genau sagen wo ich eigentlich meine
Inspiration herbekomme das sind meistens
echte Gespräche das reale Leben ist
meistens am lustigsten aber ich lasse
mich auch von Film inspirieren wenn ich
denke oh der war jetzt so schlecht ich
musste den irgendwie verarschen oder
sowas und andere Leute finden das auch
lustig also bei mir ist es meistens so
ich ich habe eine Idee und dann schreibe
ich mir die auf und dann verfilme ich
die irgendwann aber ich habe jetzt nicht
so dass ich denke oh mein Gott ich muss
jetzt die ganze Zeit ich muss irgendwas
lustiges schaffen sondern wenn ich
irgendwie denke oh das das ist aber
lustig dann dann mache ich das jetzt so
je nachdem wie ich Bock habe und die
zweite Frage war ob ich an Gott glaube
oder ob ich religiös bin das kann ich
mir ehrlich gesagt auch nicht se selber
beantworten also ich glaube nicht an die
bel ich ich bin zwar getauft und
konformiert aber ich bin nicht gläubig
obwohl ich jetzt mittlerweile also ich
war früher ganz schön antichristlich
eingestellt und mittlerweile bin ich
sehr tolerant geworden also ich finde
das okay wenn Leute glauben und sagen ja
ich habe Gott gefunden und alles
Schlechte was mir im Leben passiert ist
hat den Grund dass ich heute glücklich
bin so was hat ja auch ein bisschen was
mit mir zu tun ich habe auch viel Mist
in meinem Leben erlebt aber habe da
nicht so wirklich den den Glauben an
Gott gefunden aber ich glaube alles was
Schlechtes im Leben passiert dann
genauso viel passiert dann auch wieder
guter gutes vielleicht in der Zukunft
also es kann man nicht sagen und ja ich
bin nicht gläubig aber Leute die an Gott
glauben finde ich auch in
Ordnung